so your role changed over time the more
you're in the industry though
i have to actually learn how to say
vulgar or like booger wrangling
yeah i actually took a note like how how
does it speak
dirty like you know the vulgar notebook
i wrote every single ornament pier i
could come up here like you know
to like describe like i i read a lot of
itchy manga
oh my god you actually use manga as your
source material
oh no isn't that so ironic that like
there's essentially like a loop going on
right it's like because i guarantee that
itchy manga artists learn
how to say these things
actresses use yes
it's a recycle it's a good recycle
that's so funny you're just going green
whereas in like english porn if you're
just australian you're like that's it
that's the script
what's your nationality okay just use
that yeah just keep talking to him like
he's a close friend
i watched this uh you with porn uh that
was
what was that avengers it was about
avengers in japanese it was called
hamenjas
i don't know the us title if it was a
pun
or something but and the look was
amazing
they were all dressed in like how was
how there's so many horrifying ones
yeah have you seen the spongebob one
there's a spongebob
i've seen this one it's horrifying
spongebob i'll show you later it looks
disgusting
there's also the pokemon one as well
and do you have a squirtle no it's uh
it's pikachu
i'm just curious it should have been
squirrel right but no
it was it was pikachu but like the girl
was pikachu
oh they put this woman in like full
yellow body paint and it's disgusting
it's like okay there's misty right so
it's perfect that's the axis right and
like maybe ashen brock doesn't know no
no she's called she's called fisty
feasty
and i think i think they changed the
[ __ ]
and ash is gash
but like you think that it's misty right
and it's like perfect scenario and like
i don't know maybe pikachu watched from
the summer no
they made the girl pikachu so it's brock
i'm sorry [ __ ] and dash we are not
getting ads on this app
hey follow us on patreon and they're
just like doing it with pikachu and i'm
just like why
it would have been fine if you just did
it with misty why did you have to do it
with a pokemon who's ever
seen a pikachu and going i want to [ __ ]
that oh gosh
there's a lot of the internet i i mean
no exactly right so like as a
professional as as a true professional
what is your opinion on like the western
porn industry compared to japan
when i watch the jamen just you know i i
don't know if that's addictive of all
porn in there i'm just shocked that
how much they didn't do script wise like
they had a drama scene and that's it
like for
sex they didn't do anything like they
didn't say anything related to the story
i don't think westerners care yeah
oh that's it i'm gonna i'm gonna come
back
[Laughter]
nothing that was like people at
halloween you know
they're not even acting this isn't
professionalism too fair when you've
seen
the way they act in some of these pornos
you're like no i really don't want you
to act i
i really don't yeah some of these actors
the bathtub one that's the one
shark there's a shark in the bathtub
have you not seen that one
get out of the water there's a shark get
out of the water sure
there's a shark in the water wait
there's no shark in the bathtub
aren't you glad you had a lifeguard here
to save you have you seen that i've seen
that yeah
there's a guy in the bathtub and a woman
comes in obviously looking very sexy and
like there's a shark in your bathtub and
he's like
no there is it's really dumb it's very
dumb everyone who's seen it is like oh
yeah it's cursed
yeah i'll show you later i've there's so
many memes of just like
bad porn acting that it's it's just
become like a joke
like there's there's like youtube
channels that are dedicated to just
uploading badly actually
[Laughter]
so gross because like she's full body
paint but then they like
spread and it's like oh yeah oh no
oh no no yeah it's pretty nasty uh
courtesy of aki for showing me that oh
yeah aki finds all the weird things
yeah she showed me that one she also she
also showed me like there was a
spiderman one
everything yeah
do they do porn parodies in japan we
cannot do that i mean sometimes we try
to do it but sometimes
we have to take it back yeah but there
are some paradise ones
because of the like the fair use thing
right yeah because phase
is not a thing so much so that not even
porn can like parody it but like i've
seen a lot of like cosplay porn is
that does that count as parody or is
that like sometimes
uh can't bring the publishing company
like say
know don't do that oh i think they have
to take back something yeah yeah yeah
they were okay with fate because of
facebook that that makes sense why all
the cosplayers i've seen is just fake
because face like yeah we we want the
porn
this is how this is how people get into
our game got 30 right
yeah exactly
so we can sell more sabers saber having
sex with saber
the class
[Laughter]
did you ever do like any of that kind of
stuff like did you ever do cosplay stuff
i want my cosplay
uh i never got around to do the parody
yeah but parody if your actress name is
too strong like too well known
and that can just i don't know uh
that can be a nuisance in a way okay
because because they don't see
it yeah they don't see the character
they they see these yeah
that makes sense yeah so like how did
you then decide to go after you retired
how did you decide to then go from that
to like cosplay stuff right i actually
loved cosplaying because i looked
totally different yeah i think my first
decent cosplay was danova from
far from here from uh
what was that was everything which one
was that
what was the character name daniela
danoa
joey doesn't know something i i i don't
know either
fantasy i forgot i forgot what's okay
describe the anime what's what's the
anime it wasn't that it's a game it's
game oh it's a game
i like feet i mean oh no bru ah
drum roof fantasy there's so many
characters i forgot
yeah what is it what is faith it's one
of those countries
which game was that yeah yeah yeah from
like with
horns okay okay okay yeah yeah
i mean